one of the things i noticed about five
years ago six years ago there were two
things that i noticed that i really
didn't like
the first is that
because i'm a personality psychologist
as a researcher not as a clinician but
as a researcher i i know the literature
on gender differences in personality
because it's part of my field
and
i could tell that i was starting to have
some reluctance to deliver the lecture
on gender differences now i didn't stop
but i i felt i felt that i i was
treading on thin ice by delivering those
lectures and i thought oh that's not
good because i'm like a comedian i'm
pretty much willing to say anything that
i think is true and
you know regardless of the consequences
in some sense because i'd rather take
the consequences of what's true and i
thought this isn't good because if
someone like me who's you know rather
uncontrollably mouthy let's say is
starting to have second thoughts about
teaching what's a very serious topic and
and something about which there's a very
well-developed science then how much are
other people starting to censor and at
the same time my students many of whom
were female were telling me that they
were really
hesitant to talk about gender
differences in any of the courses they
were running and i thought oh this is
not good this is seriously not good and
so
and it's certainly the case that that my
colleagues censor themselves
increasingly on campus with regards to
the topics they're willing to discuss
and it's subtle you know because
imagine in a given lecture i could
discuss any of ten things
and three of them are taboo
well
i just won't discuss those
you know and that's that that's a kind
of invisible censorship it's not like
i'll get up and say look i could have
talked to you about gender differences
and personality but i won't because i'm
afraid i'll just pick another topic
because there's lots of topics to choose
from
and that means there's going to be a
bunch of topics that are really
important because actually the issue of
sex differences and personality happens
to be really important that people just
won't talk about and the other thing
that's so annoying about this is that
especially with regards to sex
differences and personality well let's
say
let's say that you're firmly on the side
of women just for the sake of argument
well do you admit to or deny the
existence of sex differences and
personality what's better for women
well you know the radical leftists
basically say oh well those if you talk
about sex differences then you're part
of the oppressive patriarchy and you're
attributing to women a different kind of
temperament in the attempt to continue
the suppression but i could just as
easily say it's like well wait a second
like if you want to if you want to uh
give the individual the greatest degree
of freedom you say look
you you're different from another person
you're different on the basis of a
variety of your characteristics sex
being one of them that's going to have
some effect on what sort of choices you
want to make in your life it's like go
ahead and make whatever choices you want
as far as they're a direct expression of
your being
and so if you deny the existence of
these sex differences which no one no
serious commentator in the psychological
literature in the personality domain and
those are the people who know about this
thing nobody debates whether or not sex
differences and personality exist or
that they have a biological component
no c and
what's also interesting about that is
that
none of those people are conservatives
there are no conservative psychological
researchers to speak of they're in a
tiny minority
so the people that have done the
research indicating that there are
differences between the sexes and
personality and that those differences
have a biological
in part a biological component those are
liberal and left-leaning people who've
drawn those conclusions
despite their you know despite what
their ideological presuppositions might
have suggested to them to begin with
so
well so you know it's i don't know what
to say about that except that it's it's
all appalling
i suppose the fear must be that
difference will ultimately be used for
leverage
for status sure and that's a reasonable
fear
you know because because anything can be
manipulated but but
claims of identity can of identi of what
claims that that people are identical in
some way can also be used for the same
reason
you know if i insist that
everyone is exactly the same on all
dimensions there's just as much of a
totalitarian threat lurking in there as
there is the threat lurking that will
use differences as an excuse yes and
we're also not having a serious
discussion about this it's like
yeah there are men are overrepresented
at the top of the economic apex that's
true it's a small minority of men by the
way it's certainly not men in general
but they're radically underrepresented
at the bot overrepresented at the bottom
and believe me man like nobody cares
about men who are failures they are like
off the bloody radar yeah so and and
there's no sympathy for men who are
failures
so men stack up at the top and the
bottom
and and and we don't have a discussion
about that and we don't have a
discussion about the fact that women are
radically underrepresented in dangerous
jobs although they are
or in or in or in
in trades that require like
brutal physical labor women are
radically underrepresented or or in jobs
outside women are radically
underrepresented so the complaint is
always well if you look at the top one
percent it's there are more men than
there should be
you know by pure sex division it's like
well yeah but if you look at the bottom
the reverse is true
so
if we're going to have the discussion
which i and i don't really necessarily
think we should have that discussion but
if we're going to have the discussion
then we should look across the entire
economic spectrum i wonder how much of
this debate is being governed by
unconscious forces i wonder how much of
what we're experiencing is a a
manifestation of
uh
sort of
un
where cartography has not yet been well
i think that you know a lot of it what
are you thinking about any particular
part of it
what i feel like is that the reason that
i imagine that your arguments that are
based on research are so successful is
because people are expressing feelings
as opposed to
cogent and researched arguments it feels
like there is a powerful dominant
patriarchy and no one can deny i mean
that there is power there's such a thing
as power and there are people that
benefit from structures being as they
are of course that's the point of those
structures being the way they are one of
the things i've observed is that
whenever change is discussed you know
and my tendency
has always been to be sympathetic
towards
movements that are about change or
empowerment of what might be termed
disadvantaged groups um
that change is all that when you are
curious about the resistance of change
or the different difficulties that you
face when trying to bring about change
look at who would be negatively impacted
were that change to be brought about and
usually that means that there's some
people for
you know conservatism makes sense to a
particular group of people one of the
things i felt when um reading a book was
that you know like i
i because i think you're coming from a
perspective of psychoanalysis and it
rings very the language rings true and
the analysis rings true the what i where
i feel
one question i was keen to bring to you
is when you talked about skateboarders
in the so i think it's the last but one
chapter and that spirit of a a young
people yeah courage and a willingness to
try dangerous things and to push forward
um i wonder how that sits with the idea
of a an earlier passage in the book
where you talk about the gratitude that
we should feel for you know having time
to read a book and the ability to read a
book and sort of respect for the
establishments and systems that have
been set up from which we all benefit
you know because when i you know i i
could find it difficult to dispute your
opinion
about sort of uh churlish what would
have been in the lexicon of the day
social social justice
warriors and that kind of
somewhat rootless
unresearched rage you know i i i
identify what you're saying there people
that can't keep their bedrooms tidy you
would be careful before you let them
organize an economic system but like but
but similarly
like you know where is change going to
come from who are who is going to
challenge tyranny yeah is it good
those are the sorts of of twin forces
that we have to contend with across the
political spectrum so i could run
through something quickly to put the
things that you just that you just
brought up in in in perspective let's
say okay so the first thing is is that
hierarchies if you're going to value
some things more than others then
hierarchies are inevitable
and you have to value some things more
than others or you don't have anything
like beauty or strength or something
well
competence or sure whatever whatever it
happens to be the ability to play the
flute
right it doesn't matter what on my list
well what what you know obviously if you
value music then you're going to value
some musicians more than others because
some are better so and so you have to
value things in order to move forward in
life and you have to value things in
order to have something valuable to
produce but if you play out the value in
a social landscape you're going to
produce a hierarchy and the problem with
producing a hierarchy is that a small
number of people are going to be more
successful than the majority and a very
large number of people aren't going to
be successful at all at that particular
thing it's inevitable so okay now
so so you must say well we have to put
up with that because we need to pursue
things of value
okay fine so that's the right wing
perspective is that the hierarchies are
justifiable and necessary now the
left-wing perspective is yeah but wait a
minute the problem with hierarchies is
that people stack up at the bottom and
that they tilt towards tyranny across
time and that's also true and so you
need that dialectic in society between
the right wing that says
you know
we need the hierarchies and they're
useful and you should be grateful for
them and they structure you and give you
form and provide value and the left that
says yeah but they exclude people and
people stack up at the bottom and that's
dangerous to the hierarchy itself and it
it means that people might not have
opportunity and you have to say yes to
that the problem comes and and this is
the situation we're in right now where
the radical leftists and this is mostly
a problem that really permeates the
universities the radical left to say
yeah but all hierarchies are just
tyrannical power it's like oh no they're
not
hierarchies are based on competence in a
functioning society and mostly our
society functions so you need you can't
go that far
now that doesn't mean that
that hierarchies don't tilt towards
self-interest and tyranny across time
but that's a bad thing it's even a bad
thing from the conservative perspective
you